la cinquième nuit du handicap était
organisé ce 11 juin à versailles
spectacles chants ou encore ateliers de
sensibilisation était au programme
objectif dépasser les préjugés en
montrant le handicap sous un autre
regard avec la pf on a décidé de
contribuer en apportant un fauteuil
roulant et en permettant aux gens de
d'appréhender ce qu'est réellement
l'utilisation d'un fauteuil roulant sur
la voirie taylor j'essayais de monter
sur un trottoir à l'aide d'un fauteuil
roulant et c'est hyper devises il pasky
by fo a basculé et vraiment ne pas
tomber un atelier de handisport était
organisée par l'association yvelinoise
au world solidarity boxing le but était
de montrer que le sport peut être
accessible à tous quel que soit le
handicap tu là aujourd'hui pour
vous coacher des gens différents genres
pour apprendre un peu d'abord
préparer à des paris à l'heure à l'heure
alors à leur niveau
un peu trop fatigué ce jaune ring
actuellement le regard sur le handicap
est toujours difficile parce que la
différence se fait souvent peur mais
justement ces journées là permettent de
lever justement ces différences cette
nuit du handicap était aussi l'occasion
de favoriser les rencontres entre les
personnes et de créer des liens durables
les autres années on avait organisé des
binômes et en fait des jeunes m'ont dit
cette année qu'il avait continué à
correspondre avec leurs binômes porteurs
de handicap et valides et saha pour nous
c'est une très belle réussite c'est
plutôt extrêmement convivial c'est très
agréable d'une part par par le lieu et
puis les photos avec les quelques
légendes et quelques citations je trouve
que ça ça donne un autre regard cette
journée aura permis d'ouvrir les esprits
en changeant le regard sur le handicap
l'événement organisé à versailles a
accueilli environ 1300 personnes